[Music]
anybody here like doing chores at home
yeah actually i do i you do look like a
guy who would like doing treats really i
like vacuuming vacuum i like you know
why i like shutting my brain off and
then just doing simple tasks uh like the
mindlessness of like doing something
productive like cleaning
i'm gonna have your back right now stuff
yeah washing dishes
or uh mowing the lawn i get in the zone
i just actually like washing dishes
washing dishes i don't mind washing
dishes either i actually like it it's
therapeutic i prefer folding laundry
than washing dishes
and the reason why is i don't
i don't like being at the risk of
breaking things you can't break
underwear
but then dishes try me i can
go like this and then i like i throw it
too hard or something it [ __ ] cracks
i'm like [ __ ] why are you throwing your
dishes bro you're throwing it throwing
dishware barbell we get over here he
picks up a dishwasher
[ __ ] well one time i just grabbed the
cup and i stuck my hand in and it just
broke right there look at your [ __ ]
hand dude
don't blame the cop he's scrubbing the
glass shot glass bro
meanwhile he's putting his underwear
away carefully
he's a [ __ ] idiot what's wrong with
you dude i prefer in the kitchen
[Laughter]
in the dryer poor geo bro
anyone here hate doing chores i really
don't like it i'm not a big fan of
chores
laundry can go literally fine yeah
i hate the worst
seriously oh i just tried to wash and
fold i'm going to go pick it up tonight
wait what does it do
is you just bring bags of laundry to
like a like a like it's called a
washroom they sound like some luxury
[ __ ] yeah they have a you know you can
either do coin lines it's not expensive
bro they'll wash it for you how come
they don't come pick it up from their
house
there is a service that does that you
just call it it's the thing about
putting it away i don't like it even if
they fold it i don't want to put it away
that's my thing
yeah i hate that part well i i mean it
is a lot though i paid 36 bucks for two
bags of laundry
okay 36 bucks for two bags yeah bar
would do it for you
i'll fold it i mean i don't really like
chores but if i had to choose one maybe
laundry i may be vacuuming vacuum is my
favorite they'll throw your clothes in
the dishwasher that's for sure
i'll do like i'll do a uh
i'll do washing dishes i don't like
drying though
i hang it for that
i let the air dry and i don't like
vacuuming corners
oh that's so true you know when the
[ __ ] [ __ ] specs get in the corner
and they're like eight
eight it doesn't get in there you gotta
stick your finger in and like or you
gotta take the [ __ ] tube out
i don't like i like those sound effects
i've been working on his vacuum material
bro
you know what i don't like about it
when you gotta move things yeah that's
what i don't i hate moving furniture to
get into certain spots but i'll do it
because it's a necessary evil you have
to unnecessary evil necessary evil just
like doing [ __ ] laundry bro so this
uh you know slightly upset wife a
frustrated woman has revealed that she
has to pay her husband for doing chores
around the house what do you think she
has to pay him just to pay him 40 an
hour
three blow jobs a day yeah like sexual
favors for sure blow jobs that would be
so that would be awesome dude i'd be so
doing my chores for sure every day
that's why i've ever
sure actually she pays him with video
game hours
this got weird bro this guy's a [ __ ]
not allowed to play video games this
seems like a mom child relationship
they're definitely not having sex
playing video games by yourself like a
27 year old woman first met her husband
he was a student who prioritized his
studies over getting a job acceptable
however once he finished college he
refused to get a job and decided to stay
home instead
may be acceptable
well this didn't bother as well how do
you refuse to get a job that's weird
that's easy guy refuses to grow up i
love it he's a [ __ ] this guy's a [ __ ]
yeah wallace didn't bother his wife
she's at her wit's end with how little
he helps out around the house and she
says all he does is play video games
divorce his ass
what game though yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah good question i know really chores
in the video game maybe he's vacuuming
in there he's playing sims
playing roblox he's playing warcraft
getting the [ __ ] out of here this guy's
gonna give you nothing she jumps on
reddit says i tried talking uh to him
about helping out around the house but
he claims he forgets so when i suggest
putting chores on the refrigerator he
says it's demeaning get a new
relationship the thing is i have access
to the internet as i pay the bills i
couldn't theory shut off his internet
until chores get done but i feel that's
what you do with children yeah he's a
child after many suggestions i wondered
how about paying my husband with video
game hours for chores he completed this
way he does work around the house and he
still gets to play his precious video
games i laid out what i thought was
reasonable compensation for chores they
aren't hard washing dishes for 90
minutes of game time taking out the
trash for 30 minutes putting away
laundry for two hours you know what i
know about this guy the game he plays
sucks yeah
he probably plays [ __ ] death
stranding which is like work and he
doesn't even know that real life is
actually more fun yeah death drains a
piece of [ __ ] game
you're you're a mailman it's [ __ ]
weird it's delivering stuff here's
deliver [ __ ] around dude but you still
beat the game that's how you know yeah
yeah i completed it
after 200 hours you know it was an
investment i was like god damn it you
got to see what happens at the end yeah
you know real life is much more fun
though she concludes her post by asking
reddy uses whether she is in the wrong
and while the general consensus was that
she wasn't many people did accuse her
husband for mooching off her so yeah i
mean but she's enabling it too that's
what i was saying she's probably
enabling him what would you do kelly
throw him out oh see hot
he's not paying bills he's not doing
anything there's no responsibility
that's a bad attitude baby that's the
bad thing
he's about to get me mad at you dog you
know what i'm saying
kelly's back
why do you think it's so hard for her to
do that because he got actually she
cares about him but she's mothering him
yeah that's not a relationship they're
not having sex at nighttime no
he ain't blowing that back if they are
having six he gets 120 minutes of game
time
[Laughter]
for 20 minutes of cuddling what the [ __ ]
i have i have a theory yeah that's a
trick
that's a trait it's really solid women
that stick into these situations they
have low self-esteem yeah they don't
feel like they could get better so they
try to fix that that's my theory you can
get better that's probably right
probably right this guy's playing the
[ __ ] avengers game he's a little
[ __ ] anyway that game sucks at it i
would never play that you can't judge a
guy by the game that they [ __ ] yeah that
game's like clocking into work dude but
also like look i understand about like
why people like playing video games but
after you play like an hour
like that's it nah bro i could go 48
hours go [ __ ] yourself
[ __ ] go read a book about it get out of
here bro get informed you're not going
to read a book you obviously didn't play
zelda breath of the wild look at this
gym rat telling everybody how it is with
the gamers no no i play video games bro
but like yeah what do you play [ __ ]
avengers and desperate
hey dude hold me back hold me back
hey man i like playing avengers you're
about to not be an iron man don't get
knocked out don't get knocked down i
like being iron man
[ __ ] i gotta say i can't speak on behalf
of this uh this woman even though i will
say that going going to reddit versus
just doing what you got to do seems
interesting
[Laughter]
she can't even talk to her husband just
to talk to reddit yes but i will say on
behalf of this guy this guy is a piece
of [ __ ] uh i think
i love playing video games but mooshing
off of a human being and surviving off
of them and not choosing to contribute i
think is weak actually how can you be a
husband that refuses to get a job and
then you're okay with your wife just
working all day while you chill i can't
do that you say that joe but you've
never played grand theft auto online you
don't know what it's like i have played
online you did i went 48 hours straight
i could fast like i'm going through
straight up uh spiritual experience i'm
[ __ ]
absolutely motivated he's like no
i was sitting on the toilet while i was
playing i didn't even have to take
breaks i stand down i stand down no no
but it is addicting
bro but i got it off the hook dude but i
gotta i gotta say though i'm paying the
bills still though okay so i can
understand a person being like look
give me a week
i can understand that but i need to beat
this game give me like one week
afterwards i'll [ __ ] do cunnilingus
for three hours straight right yeah
whatever it is i whatever whatever the
trade bargain is right it's really
sensitive but other than that you could
trade off with the butthole yeah
[ __ ] that's actually a good point yeah
but other than the butthole yeah there's
there's there's grounds on that if a guy
can't [ __ ] contribute if a person
can't contribute to the relationship
they need to get the [ __ ] out yeah what
is he doing he's doing [ __ ] what is the
female equivalent of staying home and
playing video games all day not doing
[ __ ]
[ __ ] are girls as lazy as guys no way
impossible for sure rarity tv reality tv
like couch potatoes reality tv
plus online shopping my neighbor does
that i can hear my neighbor she watches
daytime tv she watches like judge joe
brown all that [ __ ]
what is she what is she what she do does
she work is she doing chores while
watching no she's yelling at her kid on
the phone always
she's doing something i guess i don't
know i guess by the way if you are 69
but you're not
touching genitals uh you're touching the
butthole is that called a star 69 wait
what
you're 69 and both people are going to
town on the [ __ ] is it a star six no
that's a 96.
it's not star 69 what about this i got
motored again i'm motivated what about
the brown star
i like star 69 i think star trek let's
start with 69. that would that makes
sense to me do you remember back in the
day if someone called you and then like
they hang up right before yeah they hang
up and you're like oh [ __ ]
damn i wonder who called you could star
six nine there yeah yeah
okay and you go into town on their
[ __ ] while they're going
yeah you're munching [ __ ] if you do
star six that's how it was back in the
day yeah you guys are both munching
[ __ ] and what was the one that you
blocked some you blocked the call rd
star 68 seven i don't know that's
confusing yeah you know that's four one
one yeah yeah that's when somebody's got
their dick in your mouth and you're
going to town their [ __ ]
to collect with that what is it we had a
baby it's a boy
oh yeah you remember that yeah i do
remember that
i remember that that was during the time
the generation of like pack bell yeah
[ __ ] with 401 in a way where you would
spend hours just asking [ __ ]
hours i don't know the hours i feel like
in junior high you're so [ __ ] bored
20 minutes i could do on 401 i don't
know about hours yeah i had too many
friends for that
he also had loving parents yeah yeah i
did i did that's a [ __ ] concept
avoiding hugs for my parents for sure
for sure 401 was a great place that was
google before google google just called
me like what's the closest pizza
restaurant to here yeah we'll give you
the address yeah
are they open
about tomorrow
[Laughter]
can they deliver
anybody ever prank call the cops [ __ ]
yeah like 9-1-1 or the absolutely 9-1-1
they call you back right away yeah i'm a
responsible citizen i don't do that they
don't send the [ __ ]
out of here
i called 9-1-1 when i was like 5 years
old i remember i was in indianapolis
indiana i saw a commercial for batman
toy and i called 9-1-1 and i asked if my
dad could get me a batman toy
that's cute and then they sent a cop to
the house yeah and they arrested your
dad right they arrested my dad yeah well
they shot my dad
you